With so many feel-good chemicals in every bite, it could seem like our hankerings are purely physiological.
But scientists say, probably not.
In a study from the 1990s, volunteers were given either chocolate...
...or a pill with almost all the same active compounds.
The pill alone did not satisfy.
White chocolate, however, did satisfy.
It's made from the fat of chocolate and has the same calorie load in sweetness...
...but it lacks most of the pharmacological ingredients that are in milk or dark chocolate.
Though we can't say that white and milk chocolate satisfy because of the sugar alone.
Because in general, other sweets don't satiate those cravings.
Then there's anandamide, which was not studied in the pill experiment.
But it's fat-soluble, so it could have been in both the white chocolate...
...and the milk chocolate, explaining some of our cravings.
But there's not enough in chocolate to achieve a noticeable high.
Current calculation suggests that a 70-kilogram person...
...would have to eat about a third of his weight,...
...25 kilograms, in order to feel much of anything.
And what about the fact that women reach for chocolate more often than men,...
...especially around monthly menstruation?
That could be culturally mediated.
Scientists say our cocoa desires are more about dealing with stress...
...in a culturally accepted and delicious way than about anything else.